was kaum sie frau göring-eckardt wie
lange da die geduld vieler deutscher ist
also wie nie und nicht nur geduld
sondern auch schlichtweg die fähigkeit
im alltag das noch mal zu organisieren
noch mal die kraft zu haben den alltag
völlig umzuorganisieren mit kindern und
ich habe das muss eine der sind allen
dingen sein dass die kitas und dass die
schulen nicht zugemacht werden und das
klar ist dass wir vorbereitet sein
müssen eigentlich schon hätten sein
müssen nicht erst jetzt dann so halt
damit anfangen dass die schulen da sind
dass man im zweifelsfall oben steigen
kann auch auf den gitarrenunterricht und
das die voraussetzung in den schulen
geschaffen sind
da muss man ja ganz ehrlich wir haben
nicht über schulen und tatsächlich
gelüftet werden die frage ob man
luftfilter oder raumluft beide wie auch
immer man die dinger bezeichnen will
angeschafft werden können die dort im
grunde genommen auch seit früher
diskutiert es passiert aber nicht und da
rede ich noch gar nicht darüber dass man
vielleicht bundeseinheitlich als
pandemie wirtschaft daran denkt dass so
was passiert wir erleben ganz einfach
vor ort das ist das nicht geschieht das
macht die leute wahnsinnig wenn wir uns
anschauen dass wir dieser untersuchung
gesehen haben beim württemberg wahl des
ersten bundes einfach so eine studie
gemacht hat dass die infektionen am
allerwenigsten bei kindern insbesondere
keinen gehen dann passieren dann wäre
für mich das drehen lasst die schulen
auf also wenn die frau an die arbeit
gehen kann
dann können auch die kinder in die
schule gehen dann muss man so machen
dass die gruppen geteilt sind und so
weiter